If you had to bet on the next
presidential election based on one
trait,
what would you pick?
Wealth,
hair,
color,
family history,
illuminati membership size of their
super pack,
maybe size of their hands.
Well,
Professor Greg are.
Marie has the answer to this in his
paper on how physical traits affect our
choices in leaders.
Marie found that from 1789 to 2012,
if you had bet on the taller candidate,
you would have been right 58 percent of
the time.
That alone should probably be the end of
the video.
Fifty eight percent isn't insane.
Advantage if you consider that height,
has nothing to do with actual knowledge
of how to run a country or foreign
policy.
So with that we should be able to exit
out of this video.
Sad that our elections have been so
extensively hijacked by biological
prejudices,
but unfortunately it doesn't stop there
because our data set isn't a complete
picture yet.
Nobody decided their vote based on
height before the television because
they couldn't.
They voted based only on what they heard
from the radio and news only since 1960.
And we had televised debates where the
voters have been able to clearly tell
who is color.
So if we separate out these data sets
into before television and after
television,
we find two things.
First in the elections before 1960,
our assumptions that they were
unaffected by height turns out to be
true.
The odds of the taller candidate winning
drops to 51 percent as we would expect
if people not able to see their
candidates before voting for them.
Secondly,
in our post television data set,
our biological prejudices are worse than
we thought.
From 1960 to 2016,
the taller candidate has won 67 percent
of the time.
Also,
if one candidate is more than three
inches taller than the other,
their chances of winning go up to 83
percent.
Again,
it's absolutely insane that height
matters this much to our elections.
But although this is a bit depressing,
it is in line with what we know about
behavioral psychology.
There are many theories on why we like
color leaders.
Some studies say height is an advantage
in fights because it means you're
punching down,
which generates more forced and makes
you a better fighter and a primitive
setting.
This is how you would elect a leader.
The strongest man would eventually win.
Other theories suggest that we pick our
leaders based on who we physically look
up to.
Think of when you're a child,
your peers are always those who are
generally around your height and the
adults.
The people who know stuff are the ones
that are taller and bigger than you.
It's possible that we never get rid of
that bias when we grow up and see people
who are taller as being authority
figures,
but no matter the explanation,
one thing is clear.
We want a leader who can draw the center
of attention and dominate a room
physically.
We perceive them to be better suited for
the job regardless of whether that is
actually true or not.
We always look to the tall guy,
so if you want to know who the next
president will be when the election
cycle rolls around,
again,
it might be worth meeting the debate and
just checking who is looking up to who.